They're sneaky.
They're slimy and they're hungry for meat.
The hagfish or slime meal has earned its name due to its
unique defense mechanism. When they're agitated,
heck fish can secrete slime to choke unsuspecting predators,
even sharks, fall prey to their gunky wrath.
This makes us wonder what would happen if you fell
into a pool full of them,
what makes the heck fish so unique?
How does hagfish slime expand so rapidly?
And why is the hagfish useful to us?
This is whatever,
and here's what would happen if you fell into a pool of hagfish
hagfish I've been around for hundreds.
Of millions of years and are the only known living animal with a skull,
but no spine.
They are also jawless creatures with the unique ability to absorb
nutrients through their skin.
Using four sets of teeth on their tongue.
Hagfish like to burrow inside sea creatures,
dead and alive and digest them over time.
Their bodies.
Are lined with special glands that secrete screeny proteins.
When the hagfish feels agitated,
this slime can expand 10,000 times larger in under a
second, making it a lethal choking hazard to predators.
So could you survive in a pool full of them?
Hobbyists are actually turning their pools.
Into self-sustaining ecosystems for fish and plants known.
As an aquaponic system.
If you're feeling adventurous and want to adopt hundreds of hagfish,
you'll need a cold salt water pool to mimic their natural habitat and
enough dead fish to feed them in.
The unfortunate event that you slip and fall into the pool.
You might still be okay if you're close to the surface as
bottom dwellers, they may not even react to you being there,
but if you happen to disturb them,
the water would start to get very slimy, very quickly,
making it difficult to swim.
The slime isn't actually sticky, but it is particularly strong.
It would tangle around your toes, fingers, ears,
and the crevices of your body. If it got.
In your mouth and started to expand it in your throat.
You could choke very quickly and drown.
Eventually the hagfish would feast on your body.
It's not exactly a nice way to go. Also. You might want to be extra.
Careful if you're driving near trucks for hagfish
hagfish slime is amusing like snot,
except that it doesn't dry out.
Someone give me a tissue, please.
The mucin is made up of long fibers like spider silk,
which are arranged in small bundles, known as skeins.
When these skeins come into contact with seawater, the glue,
holding them together, dissolves, and the slime expands rapidly.
These slime microfibers are stronger than nylon thinner than human hair.
And 100,000 times softer than jello.
This makes hagfish slime and exceptionally useful and environmentally
friendly fabric. In fact, it's used to make safety helmets, Kevlar,
vests, and even airbags and researchers are investigating.
Whether it could be used as a hydro gel to hold water in soil for
farming hagfish are also considered a delicacy in Korean
cuisine and are used in many delicious stir fry recipes.
So maybe if you're careful, you could harvest them as a business.
Whatever the situation is. If you're swimming deep in the ocean,
be aware of the many risks involved,
you might even come face to face with a giant squid,
but that's a story for another. What if.